I don't feel like I deserve my squares
yeah they're possibly slightly glittery
Wow they taste a bit like a bath bump
that's Trish all sugars no like pissing
on my tongue put it on your tongue
layman like a nice fish likes it
Prosecco a gammon maybe a Bellini
champagne crisps or some sure but
someone's put like [ __ ] berries in it
what the hell is a when what is a
winterberry it actually has dried
Prosecco wine it is pretty sweet
it's a bit like a dessert Chris I would
like to replace our fruit mints with
these it smells like an old pub fakin
fake okay so we're gonna go beef sage
and gravy hmm seafood and lemon yeah not
really me we were wrong on everything
what
that's pot that's pasta Sparkle
logically these should be close just to
like pool hot tub and these are not
full-time
these are good they've got like a little
bit of what look like dirt on em mint
and lamb I think this is like a fancy
roast chicken one it smells a bit like
the lamb cat food my cats eat now that
missus basically fallacy kebab though I
mean if these were in a large glass bowl
at a party I'd be pretty impressed it
was just any lamb its salt much I'm
quite into baby sheep now it looks like
potpourri parsnip crisps possibly
cassava or don't know one time how could
you eat that you couldn't eat that with
any sort of dignity
it's perfuming they're mad sweet that's
like the sweetest thing I've ever heard
it tastes like bad caramel bacon glaze
fasteners still and honey parsnips with
truffle oil
I don't know maple and pancetta parsnip
crisps literally no not if bacon is
pancetta and honey it was maple kind of
like keeping it real English version of
this this is a smoky bacon crisp done
horribly wrong whoever was supposed to
put in the pancetta it's just [ __ ] it
off they're from Bella pub so put my
eyes bourgeois crisp Wow yeah posh
scampi or the posh roast instead of
hanging around the gold balls and
Ferrero Rocher they hand round some
Prosecco Christmas
hi hey guys yeah up here we made a
series it's coming on November 18 please
watch it get it here yeah yeah over
there you got it dude I gotta see it
it'll be released 2015 November ok